authorities in nigeria say they've
arrested the leader of a breakaway
independence group
namdi kannu will stand trial in the
capital abuja
kanu heads up the outlawed indigenous
people of biafra movement
the group campaigns for a separate state
for ethnic igbos in southeast nigeria
the mainly christian igbos say they are
marginalized by the government
the movement denies stoking violence
kanu was tried back in 2015 but
disappeared while on bail
all right for more now we are joined by
dw correspondent
uh idris in abuja it's good to have you
on the program
can you explain exactly the charges
brought against
namdi kanu
namdi kanu is facing 11 count
charge which include treason felony
inciting violence using television
radio and online while he was abroad
and then several other charges which the
nigerian government
is trying to allow him to face court
because he jumped bell and left nigeria
the court has ordered that he should be
reminded in the custody of the state
security service
till the 27th of next month
do we know where he is right now
yes he is in the hand of the state
security service officials
as ordered by the nigerian court because
when he was brought in yesterday
he appeared in a court to face the 11
count charges
which he was facing before he jumped
bell and left nigeria
and what has been the reaction there in
nigeria to this
there are different actions some see
what the government did
by bringing him back to face trial
as a legal issue because he was facing
trial and he was on
bell and he john bell so they are
supporting what the government did
but especially people from his own area
the south east
few of them are seen that he has even
been kidnapped
why should the government bring him back
why shouldn't the nigerian government
face what is bothering nigerians the
issue of insecurity instead of
concentrating on namdi kanu there is
concern
around the world that nigeria is on the
brink of having
this this separation between muslims and
christians in the country
is nigeria or are nigerians are they
aware of this
concern outside of the country about
what's happening inside
they are very aware because they are
they've been following what is happening
of course there is a wide
line between those who are agitating for
the separation
the government even came out to say okay
i am ready to negotiate those who are
seeking
to agitating to separate from the
country although the northern part has
said
allow them to go we want them to go and
we know there are international
communities who are supporting this
agenda
that is why namdu kanu as a fugitive as
they called him alleged
fugitive is getting support not only
from nigeria but from
outside because if he's not being
supported outside
he wouldn't have been doing what he was
doing
according to what many nigerians see it
they are very aware
okay dw correspondent to isis idris
in abuja with the latest tonight and
wisest thank you